in the struggle against slavery in the 19th century american slavery
you might divide the people who found slavery awful into two groups
one group was horrified by how slaves were treated
how they were fed clothed
their families broken up beaten all of that
and they devoted themselves to a struggle
to improve the condition of the slaves
better diets better clothing keep their families together
and then there was a second group of people
who were horrified not only by slavery
but by the first group of those who opposed it
they looked at their brothers and sisters in that other movement
and they said you're missing the most powerful
and basic moral issue of the time
the problem is not how we treat the slaves
the problem is that there are such a thing as slaves
the further argument they made was
even if you and we struggled to improve the diet
the clothing the housing and so on of slaves
as long as they remain slaves
whatever we win can and probably will
be taken away by the master in the future
just as it was taken away by the master in the past
which is why the solution is not improving their situation
but transforming it into something utterly different
now move forward with me to our present system which isn't slavery
it's capitalism
oh yes we could complain a little bit that wages should be a bit higher
that people shouldn't be thrown out of their homes by foreclosure
this should sound familiar to you
we were worrying and we still worry
about the conditions of the working people of america
like we might have been upset
about the conditions of the slaves back in the old south
but then there has to be a moral voice coming up
and saying the issue isn't whether workers wages should be higher
their job conditions better their security of work higher
there's a deeper and more profound moral problem
and that's the problem of the capitalist system
that there's a moral question about whether human beings
who collectively and cooperatively produce the wealth of a society
are unable to participate
in the decisions as to what is done with what they have produced